wave author and director stephen walker
chronicles the three-week period between
the bombing of hiroshima and the end of
world war ii
he spoke about it thursday at the
national press club in washington dc for
about an hour 15 minutes
thanks very much you can all hear me i i
hope um
and thank you so much for coming on
actually a most wonderful evening uh in
this glorious city
which my daughter over there has
completely fallen in love with and her
first visit here it's such a lovely
evening and it's great that you could
all come here to listen to horror
stories about the atomic bomb
um
i haven't really made any notes about
this because i want to talk to you
really from the heart about what this
book is and what it means to me and the
journey that i've taken
over the last really two and a half
years since i started the documentary i
was asked to make this documentary
back in
april 2003
um by a friend of mine who runs a
company in london called lion television
and i did everything possible to resist
the offer to make this film
not because the money was appalling
which it was
but actually because this is a really
terrifyingly difficult and complex and
frightening and challenging subject to
have to tackle
um you're dealing with one of the
seminal events in world history
obviously people use all kinds of
cliches i use them myself about the
world changing forever nothing ever
being the same again
and yet
actually what happened in my case was
the thought buzzed around in my brain
and it wouldn't go away and it didn't go
away and finally
almost reluctantly i accepted this offer
and started to make a film
and
the film i made really was was exactly
as just was described was a
was a 24 hour story it was a story that
starts at uh 8 15 on the morning of
august the 5th 1945 and ends 24 hours
later
1903 feet above a clinic
in the middle of hiroshima on august 6th
and
it took me to so many different places
and people
and became in a way almost an obsession
with me which is a very dangerous thing
for a filmmaker and indeed a nascent
writer but in this instance uh i decided
after that that this subject was
something i couldn't leave and would
write a book about
and this is the product of that book now
i just say this that i remember
somewhere in the middle of my research
about a year a year and a bit ago i
started a journey which really took me
around the world it was it was a journey
that i was very privileged to be able to
take courtesy of my publishers
um
i went to first of all the eastern
seaboard united states i was in this
city i was in new york i went across to
new mexico spent a lot of time in new
mexico
and then to san francisco and then
actually eventually across japan and
finally down to the little tiny island
of tinian in the western pacific a
little dot in the middle of nowhere
which is where the first atomic
emissions
actually flew
in 1945
and in that island i had a very
extraordinary experience i just want to
share that with you because it kind of
way in some ways kind of encapsulates
the sort of feeling that i'm trying to
put across in this book
uh it's a very small island as i say
it's about the size of manhattan this
island
and uh and so much so in fact it looks a
bit like manhattan as well from the air
so much so that uh the seabees the
construction battalions who actually
built the huge air bases
from which those missions and others
were flown in 1945 actually named many
of the streets after manhattan streets
so there was a broadway there's an 86th
street there's 112th so you go down 42nd
street it's middle of the jungle make a
left on broadway you keep going up
broadway and somewhere near about 125th
street you find yourself on the runway
from which the enola gay took off for
its mission to hiroshima
these days uh what's so extraordinary
about it is that pretty well the only
way you can get to tinian island
is from japan
which is interesting so in a sense what
you do is you take off from japan and
you fly the 1500 miles to tinian
and in fact you land very nearby on
saipan but effectively what you're doing
is you're flying that mission backwards
you're flying back over the same
featureless sea
you pass over the volcanic rock of iwo
jima
you're flying at approximately the same
height that those guys would have flown
about 30 000 feet
and
it's quite a strange sensation you're
surrounded by japanese people on board
that plane and indeed i mentioned to at
least two or three of them
that this was actually the site of the
atomic missions that they were going
back to and they were shocked because
what's actually there today is a casino
hotel it's a place where people go to
gamble
and and this is on the southern edge of
the island right about sort of greenwich
village if you think of it that way and
uh and in fact in one case one of the
japanese tourists or gamblers that was
with me actually wanted to get their
money back because it was so
distraught at the idea that this was
actually this place that had been lost
in history was actually the site of the
first atomic mission
indeed both missions i drove up in a in
a sort of jeep
northwards
to find these runways
uh which is still there rotting in the
jungle this was the biggest air base in
the world in 1945 it was absolutely
massive four huge parallel runways it's
sort of the size of kennedy airport it's
absolutely enormous it was also the
busiest air base in the world it's
called north field
and it's completely empty there's
nothing there at all just jungle
and these coral runways one of which you
can just about drive on the other three
are really kind of have succumbed to
that incredibly fertile jungle
and
i then took a walk
away
from these runways down a little pathway
that actually traversed and quite thick
jungle actually
and wound its way towards the coast
about a quarter mile i was actually
quite frightened with snakes i'm
terrified of snakes and god knows what
and i wound my way towards
this
coast through this little path
and found myself
where i hoped i was by myself
which was
on the site
of the actual assembly buildings where
the bombs which destroyed hiroshima
and nagasaki were both built or finally
assembled
and i'm stunned you've got to imagine
i'm standing on the foundations of this
building which i've read about and
spoken to so many scientists about
this was for a few short weeks in the
summer of 1945 possibly
one of the most secret places on earth
if i'd been there 60 years previously
i'd have been shot on sight for being in
this place but there was nobody there
now it was just me
and the coin of birds and the rustle of
leaves and the sound of the sea distant
surf breaking and nothing else just me
and it was a very strange feeling to be
in this place where everybody had gone
home so many years ago for what was
actually
one of this one the most extraordinary
events in history
and at that point i realized that i'd
traveled in a way in the bomb's
footsteps i'd been there in los alamos
to the bomb laboratory where it was
developed i'd been at the site in
alamogordo
where the first atomic bomb was tested
in the desert which i'll talk about just
a moment i'd followed the bomb and the
bomb
the pilots who'd actually trained
to deliver this bomb
in this really windy dusty air base 120
miles west of salt lake city a place
called wendover a place so remote at the
time that all the guys that flew from
there hated it it was actually an
extraordinary air base in which the
state line between utah and nevada went
right down the middle of the state line
hotel lobby so you could basically be
sensible and sober on one side and then
get righteously drunk and gamble on the
other side of the lobby and they all
told me about that and then of course i
also went to san francisco
and underneath the golden gate bridge in
july 1945
the uss indianapolis ship which i'm sure
many of you are familiar with sailed
with its cargo
of uranium in a 300 pound lead line
bucket welded to the flagship
lieutenant's cabin floor on its way to
tinian island and from there was taken
and delivered and dropped
on hiroshima so in a way i went to all
these places i followed in the bombs
footsteps and it gave me a sense the
focus of what my book was about i was
going to take
seminal events
in the most important three weeks in the
history of this project and perhaps some
of the most important three weeks in the
history in history generally and i was
going to try and follow
individual stories
from
policy policymakers like presidents and
secretaries of war
and very key figures in the japanese
government at the time
down to ordinary people in hiroshima
upon whom the bomb was dropped
scientists bomb makers people i'd met
interviewed spoken to and obviously the
aviators who trained in that windy dusty
salt lake
airfield in wendover for so many months
before they were shipped out to tinian
to do their job which they did so
remarkably and terrifyingly well and
that became the core of my book so my
book moves between all these different
people
as the clock ticks down towards that
final second
on august the 6 1945 which we in some
sense commemorate if that's even the
right word
this saturday
now what i'd like to do if you don't
mind is and it can be a little bit dull
doing this but i want to i want to do
this i feel quite strong as it's really
two or three accepts from my book it
should give you a little flavor of what
this is really all about and and the
tone in which is actually written before
i do so i should just stress it's very
important to understand that although i
have conceived and written this book
in a way that i hope will be engaging to
people who might not otherwise touch
this subject there have been so many
books written and so many monographs
written about hiroshima
but many people don't read about it um
and because it's daunting uh heavily
footnoted perhaps academic whatever but
everything that i have written
is as far as i can verify true i've used
my own historians training to
universities to be able to
to test myself and challenge myself
constantly
primary sources with many many
interviews i've done um
around the world so the stories that i'm
telling are real stories these are not
fake stories in fact this is one of
those extraordinary situations where as
they say you know the truth is much more
extraordinary than fiction much more
much more in this instance extraordinary
than fiction
so let me start
good place to start
which is the test of the first atomic
bomb in the new mexico desert we are
on july the 16th 1945 or 15th to 16th
1945.
the world's first atomic bomb looks like
a giant four ton sphere
uh it has wires and things sprouting out
of it and it sits on top of a 103 foot
tower in the middle of the desert in new
mexico and alamogordo
and
there is a massive electrical storm
taking place one of new mexico's worst
ever electrical storms taking place
and here is this bomb sitting in this
little shack on top of this tower in the
middle of the desert
and everyone is panicking about the
weather because there are all sorts of
concerns about what the weather might
actually do to the bomb there is also
some serious concern
that this bomb once detonated
might possibly set fire to the earth's
atmosphere and destroy the planet
completely nobody knows what's going to
happen when an atomic bomb goes off
there are actually debates in fact there
are bets taking place in base camp
which is not very far away from this
tower obviously a safe distance away
three or four miles away
where nobel prize-winning scientists
like fami enrico fami are actually
taking bets on whether or not this bomb
might destroy the earth's atmosphere by
setting fire to it this was a serious
there was a serious mathematical
probability although it's slight that
this could actually happen it was
actually worked out as a mathematical
probability they don't know what's going
to happen there's rain there's wind
there's thunder in the middle of all of
this general groves and oppenheimer
oppenheimer being the director of the
bomb laboratory in los alamos and
general grove is being this ruthless fat
powerful
as his young deputy said hard-ass son of
a [ __ ] who ran the
manhattan project and his previous job
was to build the pentagon which he did
under budget and in time
this guy
these two guys together who formed a
rather extraordinary marriage or
partnership decide there might be some
security concerns there's a possibility
of the japanese somehow some spy might
get up there and somehow sabotage this
bomb
so they decide to send a man called
donald hornik who's a physicist
to go and babysit the bomb in the middle
of this storm in the very very last
hours
and
he just gets the bombs card basically
he's the guy that sent to go and babysit
the bomb
and so i'll just read you how my book
starts chapter one of the book gives you
a little flavor of what it's all about
this story by the way was told to me by
donald hornig himself when i sat in his
living room a year ago
in cambridge massachusetts and he told
me and i and really this is exactly how
he told it to me
sunday july the 15th 9pm trinity trinity
test site 40 miles south of socorro new
mexico
don hornig stared up at the tower
the wind and rain whipped through the
steel latticework
the storm that had been building
throughout the day had finally erupted
in all its fury
flashes of lightning lit the san andreas
mountains to the south and the desert
echoed with a growl of thunder
the tower loomed 103 feet above hornig's
head
a network of black braces and girders
reaching upward like a giant electric
pylon
by now the clouds were racing so low
across the sky he could barely see the
top
which was just as well really he didn't
want to think about what was at the top
he began to climb
the wet steel slipped between his
fingers and the rain stung his eyes
making it difficult to see
he wore no safety harness
wrong by rung he pulled himself up the
ladder
once or twice he stopped and he could
see the guards below him looking up like
ants on the desert floor
they seemed a long way down
at the top of the tower a simple
corrugated tin shack rested on a square
wooden platform
it was a flimsy cheaply made structure
obviously not designed to last he wasn't
much bigger than a garden shed
hornig stepped off the ladder beside it
pausing by the entrance
a huge dimly discernible shape crouched
inside
there was a bare 60 watt bulb hanging
from the roof
hornig switched it on and peered inside
hulking on a cradle was a metallic grey
bloated four ton steel drum and it took
up almost every inch of space in the
shack
even by day it would have looked ominous
but it looked especially so now with the
wind whipping the tin walls and the dim
bulbs swaying from the ceiling and the
lightning and thunder edging nearer
a fantastic complex of cables sprouted
from its sides like a spillage of guts
or arteries as if it was somehow not
inert at all but actually organic a
growing living autonomous embryo
awaiting the moment of its birth
perhaps in acknowledgment of its essence
it's
its creators had even given it a name
a number of names in fact
they called it the beast the gadget the
thing the device
sometimes they just called it it
the one thing nobody ever called it was
what it actually was
the world's first atomic bomb
hornig squeezed down beside it the rain
pelted on the tin roof like a thousand
hammer blows the wind rattled the thin
walls of the bomb's cage
in just a few hours a scientist called
joe mckibben standing in a concrete
bunker exactly ten thousand yards to the
south of this tower would initiate the
final act in what was the biggest and
most expensive scientific experiment in
history
mckibben would press a switch on a panel
and begin a 45 second countdown
at the end of that time a number of
different things could happen
the bomb could fail to go off
or it could detonate with varying
magnitudes of explosion
or as one nobel prize-winning scientist
believed possible it could set fire to
the earth's atmosphere in the process
destroying all life on the planet
the difficulty was that nobody knew
so that gives you a little flavor
of of the sort of the tensions that
we're building
um and i decided to to go straight in
i'd make no apologies to this at all to
go straight in with that story and start
with that moment which begins three
weeks before the book actually ends in
hiroshima
what
i think
is also very important in this story
obviously very important indeed is the
japanese side of it and and i went to
hiroshima as i said and i met a lot of
different people in hiroshima a lot of
people who were survivors from the bomb
and heard many many stories some of
which i narrowed down and used in in
this book it's almost exactly as they
were told to me
through an interpreter that i have with
me
and there was one story
that really struck me which i never
forgot and and kept you know kind of
kept
turning round and round in my mind
and i'll tell you what the story was
and then how i used it
um
i met a man who must have been in his
eighties mid-eighties his name was
tsunao tsuboi and i met him in his
living room in hiroshima
uh he was clearly somebody who'd had a
very badly burned face from the bomb 60
years previously
and
we were talking about various different
things to begin with we were talking a
little bit about what hiroshima was like
just before the war and also what it was
like in the months leading up to the
time when the bomb was dropped
uh he told me about uh
the good things and the bad things he
told me about the movies that people
went to people didn't talk about this
very often
for example the hit movie in hiroshima
in 1945 was a movie called four weddings
and and in fact if you look at the
newspapers from that time which i have
indeed even the newspaper which was
printed in hiroshima the local paper on
august 6 1945 because of course it was
printed before the bomb fell
you can see you know there are adverts
actually for you know this cinema
four weddings
um
he told me about the grass the people at
he told me about the rumors that went
around the city the city had not been
bombed it had been touched twice by
bombs not significantly bombed compared
to almost every single other major
japanese city 57 of them by this time
have been virtually raised to the ground
in incendiary bombs
incendiary fire rates hiroshima not
obviously it had not because it was
being quite deliberately reserved that's
not my word that's the air force's word
for atomic attack
but in hiroshima they saw it differently
they began to wonder what was going on
and there was a rumor spreading around
the city which a number of different
people told me about which was that
actually president truman's mother
was a prisoner in the city
she was being kept captive
and that was why the city had not been
destroyed in other words it was on the
personal orders of the president of the
united states of america not to vomit
because his mother was in it in fact his
mother was in missouri many thousands of
miles away
and the president's personal orders were
if you like the exact opposite from
these
he told me all these things and we
started to talk about the day itself and
then i just asked him a question a
simple enough question i just said him
do you remember the night before the
bomb
and there was a pause
and then he
burst into tears
which was terribly embarrassing for me
being very kind of english about all of
this and i didn't want to kind of upset
him and and i said well it doesn't
matter and he said no no he said i want
to tell you something
i want to tell you something that i have
never told anybody before
i want to turn it to you
he said the night before the bomb was
dropped
was the happiest night of my life
and then he started to tell a story and
the story that he told was a love story
about
a woman that he'd fall in love with and
met earlier that summer called reiko he
was about 19 years old and he was 20 21
years old they'd met
she was sitting on a bridge when they
met
and
they'd fallen in love
and they'd spent most of that summer
together and what made it particularly
poignant was that their respective
families were not
happy with this relationship at all they
disapproved of it it was sort of romeo
and juliet thing
and
but they persisted because they loved
each other and then came the time when
he knew he had to tell her that he'd
received his call-up papers to the army
both of his brothers had been killed
in the war and he knew that it was he
was facing death there was no question
about it the americans were
very soon going to invade and and he
would be dead he'd be another statistic
and
so that night
he and reiko went to a very beautiful
garden in hiroshima called the shukayan
garden which is still there to this day
restored after the bomb it's a beautiful
japanese garden
and uh they went into the garden at
night the two of them together
and they
lay on the grass under the stars these
are his words not mine
and
they lay for a long time together
and
then for the very first time they held
hands
they didn't kiss they just held hands
that's all they did
and uh and they lay like that for a long
time and then by around midnight they
parted at the gate and he went one way
and she went the other way
and the next day the bomb was dropped
and he
searched for his lover
in the ruins of the city
um
about the time that they parted
at that garden
gate
the crew of the innola gay would have
been just sitting down to a breakfast of
pineapple fritters that's what they had
for breakfast it was paul tibbetts his
favorite pineapple fritters before being
shipped out to
the enola gay to take off to hiroshima
with a bomb that was dropped on the city
so those kind of contrasts really made i
found very poignant and that was one of
the stories that i told and what i
decided to do in this book
was in a way to bookend to start and
finish the book with that love story for
various different reasons partly because
it moved me hugely partly because i
thought it was an interesting way to
start a book on hiroshima to start with
a love story these two people in this
garden on that night this is not any
garden but it's not any night and yet
it's something perhaps all of us in some
different ways might be able to identify
with and so that's what i did and i just
if i may we'll just read you the what i
call the preface
to
the book
this is not chapter one which i just
read parts of this is the preface before
it
sunday august the fifth nineteen forty
five shukayan garden hiroshima
for the rest of his life
tsunao tsuboi would never forget how
beautiful the garden looked that night
the trees the lake the little rainbow
bridge the ancient wooden tea houses
dotting the banks the smell of fresh
pine the white herons sleeping on the
rock the perfect stillness of it all
outside beyond the garden walls the city
slept in the darkness
in the blackout it was almost possible
to believe there was no city out there
at all
no houses no army no war
as if he and reiko lying together under
the stars
were the only people alive in the world
that is how he remembered it the night
before the bomb
as always they had to be discreet
the authorities not to mention their own
families disapproved of unmarried
couples spending frivolous hours in each
other's company
these were times of self sacrifice and
denial
every day the newspapers and hiroshima
urged their citizens to work harder and
longer and faster to focus all their
energies on the single goal of victory
japan was facing its greatest test in
history
this was no moment for love
but reiko was
beautiful tsuna remembered the first
moment he'd seen her earlier that summer
by the ota river
she was sitting on a bridge with a party
of other girls and she was laughing
he was very shy
perhaps there was something about his
shyness that appealed to her
or perhaps she liked him because there
were so few healthy young men still left
in the city
he was 20 and she was younger only just
out of school
her movements were full of grace and
years later he would remember there was
something in her voice and her smile
that was like the breath of summer
they saw each other all through that hot
july
sometimes she sent him letters with just
the faintest whiff of scent
a luxury in those times of war
but they never kissed they never even
touched
until that final night
she had cried when he told her
of course it was inevitable he was young
and the war wanted him
time had run out for both of them
he would be in the army by september
only a few short weeks away
they lay on the grass and she cried
and that was when they touched hands
he will never forget that
at some point in the evening there was
an air raid alert but still they did not
move
they were often alerts these days as the
americans passed north over the city
they flew high in their silver plains
sometimes so high that in daylight all
you could see was a brilliant white
trail in the blue sky
but they always took their bombs
elsewhere
a little after midnight they parted
they said goodbye at the gate reiko
walked away down the street
tsunam watched her go until she
disappeared around a corner
she never looked back
then he turned slowly towards his home
the memory of her touch still fresh in
his mind
afterwards he would remember this as the
happiest night of his life
he looked up at the sky
the stars were clear and brilliant
tomorrow
was going to be a beautiful day
so
that's a little bit of uh the beginning
of the book um if i could i'm have i got
time just to move on to a little bit
what i'd like to talk about now is
obviously the moment from
impact on the city itself um
this was a really difficult thing to
write about for obvious reasons i mean
it's a fantastically banal thing to say
obviously it was a very difficult thing
to write about and i'm writing about it
from numbers of different perspectives
from the perspective of the ground from
the perspective of the plane from the
bomb makers also from the politicians as
well
um
it became at one point almost impossible
to write i'd love to share with you just
what that feels like um there's a point
at which
language stumbles
when you try to describe this this pain
and this horror and and you literally i
mean the expression that i used at one
point was that
was is that the adjectives begin to pile
up like dead bodies in the streets i
mean that might sound very kind of
clumsy but what i mean by that is that
you you literally there's nothing but
silence at some point you cannot
describe this stuff without it sounding
repetitive or trivial or pointless and i
did find it very hard to do until i
decided to write about how difficult it
was to write about it and in a way that
became the key
to to describing what what happened and
obviously holding on to individual
personal experiences i'm not just
talking about japanese i'm talking about
guys in the plane and elsewhere as well
because the experiences were fascinating
and raw on all sides
so what i'm going to do very briefly is
just to read you two small sections if i
may uh of the moment of impact i'm going
to just read you the first moment i'm
going to read you is literally a very
clinical description
of what actually happened
in the first moments when the bomb was
actually dropped
it's not personalized at all in the way
that other bits that i've read to you
have been it's simply a clinical
description of what happened when that
bomb dropped and then i'm going to read
you a little bit about the reaction from
the another gay when the plane uh was
literally just diving away from the bomb
having dropped it
just to get set a little bit of uh of
background here we're at 31 000 feet
over the city in the universe there are
three planes up there
um one of them carries photographic
instruments one carries
observers the third is the enola gay
which is carrying the bomb
uh the bomb is dropped over a t-shaped
bridge the iowa bridge in the center of
hiroshima which looks really from the
air like like fingers of an outstretched
hand a lot of rivers
uh and this bridge at the center of the
mall very distinctly standing out from
30 000 feet the bomb tumbles out of the
bombay
and it drops
for 44 seconds
through the air
and indeed in tests that were done for
this particular bomb design the
ballistics of the bomb were very poor
which meant that it actually made the
most terrible sound when it dropped a
lot of the scientists i spoke to
talked about this thing i've never read
before but i'd heard about this from
these scientists it shrieked and wailed
like a banshee shout as it came all the
way down it really made a terrible
racket
um and
you know one wonders that this might
have been or would have most certainly
been the last sound that thousands of
people heard without knowing quite what
it was this shriek as this bomb kind of
ripped at almost the speed of sound its
terminal velocity towards the ground
the bomb explodes 1903 feet above a
clinic 200 yards away from the aiming
point which is this ioe bridge
i follow the bomb down at the end of the
previous chapter and then i pick up
just in the immediate aftermath
of the detonation so i'll just read that
bit to you now
the impact
was at once immediate and catastrophic
in the first billionth of a second the
temperature at the burst point reached
60 million degrees centigrade 10 000
times hotter than the sun's surface the
heat almost instantaneously expanding
outwards across the city in a visible
searing alien unimaginably brilliant
flash of light
afterward they gave the flash a name
pica or lightning
the opening act in a terrifying drama
but for many who survived it was also
astonishingly beautiful a swirling wave
of myriad colors of electrically vivid
greens and blues and reds and golds that
burned into the retina and seemed to
last forever
these witnesses were fortunate
before the flash even ended thousands of
other human beings were already dead
burned beyond recognition by the extreme
primal heat instantly carbonized into
little charred smoking bundles where
they stood or sat or slept or walked
littering what was left of hiroshima's
streets within a one kilometer radius of
the hyper center the thermal energy
contained in that single moment's flash
was intense enough to evaporate internal
organs literally boiling off intestines
in less than a fraction of a second
birds ignited in midair
telegraph poles trees clothing thatched
roofs wooden buildings household pets
and entire streetcars spontaneously
combusted steel-framed buildings
liquefied like wax rubble and bone fused
together in a single amorphous mass
watches and clocks stopped suddenly
their hands permanently burned into
their faces forever recording the
precise moment of detonation
hundreds of fires sprang up
simultaneously all across the city
overwhelming the fire breaks so
carefully prepared in the months before
accidents of clothing determined how and
whether people died
black or dark colored garments absorb
the heat making it
white or lighter colors reflected it
in some cases individuals were so
completely incinerated that nothing
remained but their shadows
one man was sitting on the steps outside
a bank 260 meters from the hyper center
when the fireball struck
all that was ever left of him was the
imprint of his pose scorched into the
stone like a photograph
the heat was visceral and horrifyingly
destructive as if the sun had suddenly
descended to earth
and it all happened in the first three
seconds
so that's
i'm sorry
this is 8 15 in the morning
japan time 9 15 as far as the crew is
concerned
so if i may i'll just read you finally
one other section which is the view of
the same event from the air this is from
the another gay at 31 000 feet just i
need to give you a couple of character
names bit boring but i'll just tell you
the as you i'm sure possibly know the
command of the mission is paul tibbetts
uh he's the pilot flying the plane still
alive today age 90.
and the tail gunner is a man called bob
karen um bob karen rather remarkable man
died in 1995 but i interviewed a number
of people who knew him well including
his best friend at the time uh he
becomes one of the key stories in my
book
he was the rear gunner the enola gay was
only armed with a tail turret they took
everything else out they stripped the
planes out completely so they were going
to be able to carry this very heavy bomb
so basically unarmed apart from the tail
karen was a very small man about five
foot five um and he fitted into this
claustrophobic turret uh he carried with
him all the way to hiroshima
not only several packs of lucky strikes
which he smoked all the way there and
back
but also a photograph of his wife
uh and his little baby that were
dangling in a photograph from his oxygen
chart
so they were with him all the way there
and back and and gave him sort of sucker
if you like as he as he as he flew this
mission
um he also carried with him a camera
little k20 was called pistol grip camera
that was given to him at the very last
moment by the photographic officer of
the squadron uh just before he boarded
the plane
and the guy said to him look you're
gonna have a ringside view here
i want you to take any photographs you
can either don't reset the aperture
don't reset the focus you set it all for
him just press the button whatever you
see just press the button just press it
so he gave this guy the camera
and sure enough as the airplane dived
away from the shock wave
of the bomb
trying to flee the blast wave as it
rushed towards the airplane
bob karen picked up his camera and i'll
just read you uh what he said
bob karen saw it first
from his turret at the rear of the plane
he had a ringside view looking directly
back at the city as they dove away
one minute he was peering through his
world as goggles barely able to see the
sun through the darkness the next he was
blinded by a terrific flash
at that moment enola gay was 11 and a
half miles from the bomb burst the
dazzling light filled the plane
for several seconds every part of it was
bathed in a strange unearthly radiance
tibbetts experienced a peculiar tingling
sensation on his teeth and the distinct
taste of lead on his tongue
his fillings he later learned were
interacting with the bomb's radiation
nobody spoke
then karen suddenly yelled over the
intercom an incoherent animal shout of
warning
through his goggles he watched in
astonishment as something that looked
like the ring of a distant planet
detached itself and came hurtling
towards him
before he could utter another word the
shockwave had caught up with them
it smashed against the fuselage tossing
the big bomber up in the air like a
scrap of paper a voice shouted over the
intercom in panic the plane bucked
violently under the impact tibbetts
fought to keep it under control
at that point enerly gay was still
traveling directly away from the city
only bob caron and the tail could see it
he removed his goggles and now he was
staring through his windscreen
in amazement
boiling up from the clock from the
ground was a spectacular and terrifying
mushroom-shaped cloud
at least a mile wide with a fiery
blood-red core it was climbing and
expanding at an astonishing rate a
monstrous angry purple grey mass of
turbulence punching up into the skies at
almost 10 miles a minute
beneath it hiroshima had completely
disappeared
everything down there was burning
thick black smoke covered the entire
city rolling out into the surrounding
footholds foothills and into the valleys
like lava spilling from a volcano
karen grabbed his camera and started
shooting
the gun sight got in the way he asked
tibbetts to turn the plane five degrees
pointing the lens instead through the
escape hatch window to his right
one after another he snapped images of
the mushroom cloud seven of them in all
each frozen black and white frame
capturing those first instance of
hiroshima's destruction
they would stay in his memory forever
i can still see it he said years later
that mushroom and that turbulent mass
it was he said a peep into hell
the co-pilot bob lewis picked up his
pencil and turned to his log
my god he wrote what have we done
if i live for a hundred years i will
never quite get these few minutes out of
my mind
in fact the
pilot co-pilot bob lewis
who wrote this log all the way through
the trip in which i found a facsimile of
in the smithsonian museum
and has actually a drawing of the
mushroom cloud that he makes minutes
afterwards his previous entry to that
it's quite extraordinary he says
there will be a short intermission while
we bomb the target
and then you get this my god what have
you done
and and it's quite chilling to read that
that is the moment when it happened
so that also gives you some sense of how
i'm i'm dealing with really the most
difficult part of it all and really the
last act of the book is about the impact
of that moment and how it affected those
people who were most
actively
involved in it
so anyway that's really all i wanted to
say from this perspective um and and
obviously i know i've gone way over time
here i'm going to get told off this so
why don't i take any questions from
anybody who've got any questions for me
i'll be happy to do my best to answer
them i think i've been told that when
people do ask questions if they could
possibly go up to the microphone that
would really help matters in turn okay
yes
was there consideration of just more
theory you know how seriously was the
collateral and civilian damage
you know by the u.s government uh
and
i'm curious on the part of japanese the
role
when it was it seems like the bottom
probably
allowed us to demand this complete
surrender and
forcing an emperor to deny his
claim the divinity
uh i mean do you see this all kind of
well let me let me just uh i should i
should answer quite a briefly on this um
actually just before the crews took off
uh they were blessed
uh by a priest uh by the chaplain which
i think is very standard um who blessed
their mission um and uh
blessed the men who were taking
the war against our enemies i think you
said i actually have the text of it in
the book
um
some of the guys there were religious
others were not it was a very
interesting story of a guy called this
guy bob lewis actually who um
i know and actually not bobless another
guy who was actually on the the captain
of the great artiste it was called which
is the observer plane who went to
confession that morning
but because of security restrictions was
not able to confess what exactly was he
was confessing uh so it made for an
interesting confession um but on the
larger scale it's very interesting you
talk about religion the
target selection committee uh i
interviewed the last surviving member of
the target selection committee
uh that chose the target of hiroshima
and in fact the first target as you
probably know was going to be kyoto
a city of a million people japan's
oldest actually it's original capital uh
and obviously the most important
religious center in japan and one of the
reasons why it wasn't chosen was because
henry stimpson the then secretary of war
had actually visited kyoto as a tourist
twice in the 1920s and loved the city
very much
and as a result of his love for that
city and his appreciation of its
importance in japanese culture he
actually persuaded the president not to
drop the bomb on kyoto so because
simpson happened to be a very happy
tourist in kyoto
in 1926
kyoto has spared atomic destruction when
those guys are sitting around a table
deciding which city to bomb
they actually
decided at one point or disgust at one
point the possibility of following the
atomic bomb
almost immediately with a full-scale
incendiary raid the idea being to send
in the bombers
and drop
incendiaries and napalm on the city at
the point where it was most vulnerable
this was discussed very seriously
um and the reason they didn't do it was
not for any kind of religious or other
scruple the reason they didn't do it was
because they were worried that it would
muddy the effects of the bomb it would
make the impact of this new weapon less
obviously discernible and the most
important thing here was public
relations the word is not mine it's
theirs at the time the pr of the bomb
was as important as the actual bomb
itself the fact that this bomb was a new
weapon and could shock the japanese into
surrender was the key so you know you're
talking about a level of kind of if you
like a very cynical destruction
that uh is a long way from any kind of
obvious sense of christian ethic that i
can understand but also i can understand
perhaps the context of the time in which
that decision was taken
sorry yeah
even if there was just the slightest
possibility of the earth's atmosphere
catching on fire and destroying all life
on the planet that the u.s government
would would take that chance and test
the bomb now
was it because the scientists felt they
could rest safe in the knowledge that if
indeed that did happen there would be no
bad public relations
why would they do that well actually
that's the point that i do make in the
book uh that is actually true i mean
they wouldn't be around to have to
justify that well i mean the
mathematical probabilities of that
happening were not huge
um it was all to do with the temperature
and was the temperature hot enough
literally to set fire to the earth's
atmosphere uh a mathematician hans beta
actually calculated the probabilities
and they were relatively slight
probabilities but really nobody knew
what was going to go on and actually the
impetus to get this thing tested and
moving was terrific it's very important
to understand the roller coaster that
the manhattan project had become by this
time it was massive we're talking about
a project which cost 2 billion 1945
dollars of taxpayers money we're talking
about a project which at one point
employed well over a hundred thousand
people entire cities have been built to
man production plants which in
themselves in some cases were half the
size of the state of rhode island in
order to make this thing happen the
entire silver deposits the united states
treasury have been melted down to get
uranium processing parts working this is
huge you know and for some guy to say
well you know something you know there's
a real there's a slight possibility that
we might actually destroy the planet in
all life as we know it let's not do it
you know i mean it just wasn't real in
exactly the same way as when people turn
around and say well why did truman make
this decision to drop the bomb well
truman himself said it was no great
decision it was not a decision this is
his words you had to worry about and the
reason why he said that which sounds pop
you know terribly callous to us today is
can you imagine a situation in which
truman
sent in the boys
into japan
and then turn around to his taxpayers
and said you know guys i actually had a
bomb which you guys have paid for it
cost two billion dollars but actually i
decided not to use it and it could have
ended the war and your sons needn't have
died i mean it's not thinkable
it's not real that's not how the real
world works as we all know today doesn't
work like that so it's a roller coaster
if that answers your question there is
no way these guys can simply tell us
actually we've had second thoughts you
know we're not going to go ahead with it
in fact they were just as worried it was
going to be a dud and general groves
this amazing sort of enormously large um
tough guy that ran the manhattan project
and was a total chocoholic actually was
one of his more endearing features he
used to keep her had an age whose job
was to top up chocolate bars in his safe
along with top secret files of the
atomic bomb he said if this thing
doesn't work he said if this thing
doesn't work he said they will stick me
in a dungeon so deep in fort leavenworth
they'll have to pump sunlight in
so you know he was worried about a dud
just as much he's worried about setting
fire to the earth's atmosphere i'm still
am i all right i'm okay
okay fine yeah
what channels did the government in
tokyo become aware of the extent of the
devastation and how long did it take him
to glean that great question
again it's it's part of the story of my
book actually it's very dramatic story
actually um within about
there was actually there were no sirens
that went off when the bomb was dropped
uh it was there were warnings coming in
as these bombers were approaching but it
was too late to to start the sirens the
there was an announcer in the radio
booth at the hiroshima's local radio
station called masa nobody furuta
who actually began to get the words out
over the radio broadcast the people of
rochester there were three planes
approaching and what usually happens
then as an air raid alert starts up um
but at that moment the radio station
goes off air because the bomb drops in
fact he was
he was literally hurled right up into
the air the entire radio station tilted
on its side at that point the tokyo
operator of the equivalent nhk japanese
national broadcasting noticed that
hiroshima's station had just suddenly
gone off the air 40 minutes later
these signals people on the railways in
japan railways noticed that there was a
signal break in the line just north of
of hiroshima they couldn't get through
to the city
and then about two hours after that a
reporter and this is in the book from
the domi news agency
um who had actually been in the center
of the city
uh just before the bomb had gone off but
had gone to visit a friend of his uh and
stayed with his friend because he was
actually waiting for a suit or a pair of
pajamas to dry
um and as ronald didn't go back to his
home in the center of the city where he
would have been killed he then goes back
in afterwards he's a reporter and he
sends one of the most famous news
flashes of all time to his he managed to
get to a telephone and one of the very
few lines it's still working and he
manages to get the news out to tokyo and
he says in this news flash that that the
city has been hit by a huge bomb and at
least 80 000 people are dead
and the guy and this side tells a story
and there's a primary source where he
describes
japan which has been translated for me
the
the uh his boss on the other side you
know in tokyo does not believe him he
simply refuses to believe that this
could have happened um and he actually
refuses to broadcast this or have
anything to do with it at all that night
on the six o'clock news in japan there
was a reference to some american bombers
dropping some bombs on japan
and some damage but nothing more on
hiroshima forgive me and some damage but
really was by by later that evening that
it was becoming obvious that something
horrific had happened to the city at
that point
um the news basically the president the
president united states statement which
said that an atomic bomb had dropped on
the city of hiroshima
with a power of 20 000 tons of tnt went
across the airwaves was intercepted by a
guy in tokyo who made six recordings of
the president's statement and then
cycled through glistening potato fields
that's how he remembers it to his uh
superior and very quickly that news was
passed to the prime minister
and it was obvious then that something
horrific had happened and as part of
that statement the president made he
said that the japanese do not now
surrender he said famously they will
face a reign of ruin from the air the
like of which has never been seen on
this earth before
okay
yeah hello mr walker um i lived in japan
four years and i've been to new mexico
some of these places you've been to uh
yeah two questions i'd really like to
ask this quickly the relationship
between oppenheimer and groves is a bit
bizarre to say at least great
relationship groves didn't want to be
there it was kind of forced there
oppenheimer was a security risk
according to the government yet they're
joined at the hip to create this monster
of a bomb
and yet they both somewhat benefited
from it in a sense prestige and stature
so sure
second question has to do with this bomb
seems to have historically warped
the history of this period where the
united states you know during the 50th
anniversary smithsonian they really
couldn't put together a thing because
they started turning to a political
football which got very nasty and ugly
on the other hand having lived in japan
a lot of japanese school children get
taught that world war ii was well they
tried to get rid of european colonialism
and then they dropped the bomb on them
and forgot about korea and china and
activity that happened there so i find
this bomb not only kind of
like this monstrosity you talk about but
even historically oh absolutely it's
become part of the country's ability to
understand the bomb and maybe your book
will fill in some of those gaps yeah
well let me tell you i mean actually i i
devoted a little bit i mean i think the
relationship between oppenheimer and
graves is fascinating and also quite
comic actually
um i mean you know groves is
extraordinarily large i mean his his
weight was a secret almost as classified
as that of the atomic bomb program uh
was famously rude to everybody who
worked with him in fact the only person
ever did work with him was his secretary
mrs jean o'leary he was a a widow um in
her 30s he was the only only actually
only person in the pentagon office pool
who actually stood up to groves and
simply shut up when he was rude to her
so the result was he employed her
permanently and in fact she knew more
about the atomic bomb program than the
president of the united states she was
known as major o'leary terrifying figure
and i think he was actually quite scared
of her he was a complete bastard i mean
his his deputy called him the greatest
son of a [ __ ] i've ever known and also
the most capable um he was uh you know
he this is in 1945 he employed a headset
in which he kind of balled commands
through his various kind of i mean his
empire was across the world
um he was very tough but he was the guy
that was needed to get this thing
actually working on the other hand
oppenheimer uh is the exact opposite
he's kind of a very thin cadiver of a
man you know he's he's a corpse like man
he weighs 116 pounds by the time of the
uh trinity test i mean he's on five
packs a day by then i mean he's really
smoking himself into an early grave
indeed he died finally of throat cancer
in the sixties he um he's very very sane
he's a very very nervous man indeed um
he's a man who believes in an open
society he thinks that scientists should
be able to talk to each other groves
isn't interested in that groves thinks
he's a security freak i mean groves
really is a security threat not he
actually
sammy set spies on oppenheimer and
bugged his phones and tapped his
everything
but he also was such a security freak
that even his own family his wife and
his two children who lived actually
quite near here in washington
had absolutely no clue what he was doing
every single day of his life
when he went into the office
running the most expensive and most
important weapons program in history and
the first time they found out about it
was actually on the day the bomb was
dropped in hiroshima when he then rang
up his wife
and said um you should listen to the
radio today i'm on it
and they at 11 o'clock he said and they
switch on the raiders in the book they
are switching on the radio and they hear
that this man that's been living with
them for the last three years going to
his office just in the new war building
just across from the pentagon is
actually the man who is responsible for
the whole of this program had no and
they actually say we were completely
flabbergasted when we heard it was
dick's bomb that was dropped on the
japanese i mean we was flabbergasted as
the japanese is the expression that she
uses when she's interviewed by cbs and
and so you know unquestionably you know
um this relationship is an extraordinary
one and and and yet absolutely pivotal
the one key thing about groves apart
from the fact that he terrified
everybody was the fact that he was a
brilliant charge of character i mean had
an uncanny instinct for character sure
he was a right-wing bastard at one level
you know absolutely and and oppenheimer
had associations
with people who are who are communists
although himself was never a member of
the communist party
but he saw
that oppenheimer was not
the most brilliant of scientists in the
nuclear project which had a you know its
fair share of super-sized brilliant egos
you know he was not a nobel prize winner
he saw that but he saw he was very
ambitious
and he recognized that by putting him in
charge of all these as he said you know
these eggheads who couldn't as he once
described it run a faculty meeting let
alone a bomb program
you know he realized that this guy would
actually
would actually keep them all in control
because he had to prove himself
he was a mercurial brilliant talent but
he wasn't a deep thinker and and
actually it's so improved you know he
kept them all in line and that's what
gave him his prestige that's what gave
him his importance so they kind of
needed each other in a way it was a
fantastic relationship as far as as you
know as your other point is concerned i
mean the answer is simply yes
yes it's a political football and i
think we'll continue to be a political
football for time immemorial
that answers your question
this question addresses the survivors of
hiroshima um they've been living with a
sort of second shock wave if you will
and that is a greatly increased risk of
cancer due to their radiation exposure
and secondly they've had to deal with
survivor guilt and i wondered if when
you talk to the survivors if they talk
to you about how they felt how they felt
about these two issues related to their
own survival of this ghastly event
the
issue of radiation sickness is a is
obviously a profound and complex one i
tell you something which is quite
interesting um
from my reading of the of the archives
um i spent some time in the national
archives in washington
and obviously interviewed and some key
people who were involved in that project
he was still alive you know this is
what's extraordinary about the privilege
i've had is i'm dealing with something
which is which is not exactly history
it's in that twilight zone of memory and
history which is why i think it's so
important and why i was able to write
this book
but one of the things that's very clear
is that they were not expecting they
genuinely were not expecting the
radioactivity of the bomb to be the key
killer in the bomb what they were
genuinely expecting was the heat of the
bomb which i describe and also the blast
wave the shock wave my book title of the
bomb
to be the principal killers effectively
um not so much the radioactivity indeed
they're a memoranda from
oppenheimer which describe how he sets
in very very specific tests they set the
demolition height of the detonation
height forgive me of the bomb at about
1850 feet and that was designed to be
the most effective detonation height for
the maximum demolition of structures
they're not talking then about
radioactivity they're talking about so
they've felt that the higher you go the
less radioactivity they'll be if you
detonate it on the ground you get
massive radioactivity higher up less
radioactivity they're looking at other
things even at that point um there is an
extra this gives you an insight into the
mentality of the time the bomb obviously
makes this tremendous flash
at the test in trinity the flash was so
extraordinary
that uh there's a very famous story a
documented story of a blind girl called
georgia green he was on her way to a
music lesson a violinist in albuquerque
she was being driven by her brother joe
or brother-in-law actually i should say
joe it was obviously still night time
when the bomb went off
she was 50 miles away
and she grasped her brother-in-law's arm
and said what's that light
so this is a bomb so bright that it
could make a blind girl see it see the
light
so you're talking about an incredible
flash now immediately afterwards several
very key and prominent
figures
in that program
wrote a memo to oppenheimer and groves
which i have a copy of and which is in
my book in which they actually suggest
that they could exploit this blinding
brightness from this bomb by dropping
super this is not my word it's theirs
super powerful sirens at the same time
as they drop the bomb
and so that people will hear the sirens
and look up at the precise moment when
the bomb's flash occurs thus blinding
them even if they don't kill them this
was actually suggested in a memo very
clearly about a week or two afterwards
and it's suggested very clear that they
should do this they're not looking at
radio activity they're looking at other
things however of course people did die
of radioactivity and you asked me about
the survivors well
there was one story
that hugely affected me
of a doctor a man called dr shuntaro
hida who told me his story uh in osaka i
think it was uh he was a remarkable man
who was actually in a little village
called jessica six kilometers just to
the north of hiroshima when the bomb
went he describes this in my book he was
actually looking after a little girl age
six who had a heart condition and he was
at the point when he was actually
injecting a sedative
with a syringe actually into her arm
but the shockwave struck the bomb went
off he had a sort of grandstand view of
it a bit like bob caron and the tale of
the another gay and the extraordinary
thing is is he tells this story which
really stuck in my mind
where he
grabbed a bicycle
and he started to cycle down this long
white dusty road towards the mushroom
cloud in the city
and uh
and he turned a corner
and
and he
actually was going so fast at that point
that he actually fell off his bike the
bike skidded and he felt he's not quite
answered the question but it does in a
moment i'll explain he fell off his bike
and fell into the road
and as he got up and picked himself up
and wiped the dust off his clothes
he saw
this object
coming towards him
that's how he describes it this object
coming towards him
and the object had
huge bulging eyes like golf balls and a
massive gaping mouth like it might be
grinning
and there were strips of what he thought
was clothing hanging from its arms i say
it because he didn't know whether it was
a man or a woman or indeed even really a
human being
he thought at first it might be clothing
in strips and then he realized it was
actually burned flesh
and this thing was staggering
towards him and he was so horrified
he backed away and as he backed away
collapsed
and then convulsed
and then appeared to die
and he went towards this thing this
monster
and he's a doctor and he thought i've
got to do so i've got to do something
and he just didn't know where to touch
the flesh at all and finally he very
hesitantly remember him telling me this
it was quite extraordinary told me this
he sort of touched the flesh
the burned sort of blackened flesh on
this thing
and
then he said a prayer
and stood up
to get back on his bicycle to continue
his journey down into the city because
if they're gonna need a doctor they're
gonna need a doctor
and then as he looked down this white
road he suddenly saw
hundreds if not thousands of these same
figures
coming up the hill towards him
all looking the same all with their arms
outstretched and these horrible strips
of black and flesh hanging from their
arms and all coming towards them and
they were
literally became thousands of them he
actually said and i quoted him when he
gave me this interview he said my god
how many of them are there
you know and they were all coming up the
hill
so he tried to treat them in his little
village hospital they had nothing there
but a bit of soybean oil and some rags
and they were doing their best and he
had this description that he would go
out amongst these people thousands of
lying in the fields with a little torch
and having to make decisions about which
ones to treat and which one's not and
talk about how the ones that were beyond
treating would follow him
with their eyes and and yet there was
nothing you could do about it at all
thousands and one extraordinary story
about a naked girl
who was rushing she was sort of
obviously hysterical she was rushing
amongst these bodies and other people
tried to get her to cover up her legs
they hadn't been burned in the way the
bomb was so instantaneous her upper path
was completely burned but her legs were
almost obscenely naked and white and
untouched he describes that detail she's
in the book and and and how other people
around were trying to kind of cover her
up to give her some sense of modesty in
that moment you know and she was
flinging their clothes away
and
and then of course what started to
happen was that people began to get
dysentery and then other things began to
happen so you know that came later and
as you rightly say it continued and they
say some historians argue that 30 to 40
000 people died in the four or five
months after the first say 80 or 90 000
died from the first day or two of the
impact the bomb from radiation poisoning
you actually rightly say that many live
with those effects to this day
but is it actually possible that u.s
scientists didn't know that there would
be no they knew there would be radiation
they absolutely did but they thought the
impact would wipe out most of the
possibilities absolutely there would not
be so many yeah yeah yeah i mean in fact
that in fact
that was one of the things that they
were determining in the test uh indeed
uh there were fallout monitors right the
way through the state of new mexico and
beyond during the test through that
night are guys waiting in jeeps ready to
evacuate entire cities if the fallout
cloud went that way guys with they had
they chose names from uh from the wizard
of oz it was like the tin woodsmen you
know and their role was basically to
evacuate entire populations that night
so all these sleeping americans who
might themselves have had to be
evacuated because the fallout club was
coming their way in fact the cloud went
five times round the world before it
dissipated from the atomic test in new
mexico
did truman tell a churchill in uh stalin
at potsdam or when did they find out
about the atomic bomb
um
what were the japanese fighters on the
day that bob was dropped sorry the
japanese
were the japanese fighters how the
fighting planes oh right fighter planes
yeah sure uh well on the first question
um truman uh did actually obviously had
told churchill knew about the bomb
project and the british scientists were
involved in the manhattan project he
knew everything about it in fact when he
was told by the secretary of war and
read
general groves account of the trinity
test famously um he said he said
stimpson he said what is electricity
meaningless what is gunpowder it's
nothing he said this atomic bomb
is the second coming in roth it's a
great churchill phrase and very chilean
of course um so churchill knew stalin
was not supposed to know about the bomb
um
in a very very carefully staged managed
event in the middle of the potsdam
conference one evening after one of the
sessions
truman casually wandered over to stalin
and told stalin that they had a weapon
of unusual destructive power which they
were intending to use on the japanese
church was watching every moment they
worked this out together like a couple
of school boys and stalin just said oh
that's great do use it and said nothing
more and stalin and and churchill and
truman were absolutely convinced that
they got away with it and stalin knew
nothing about this bomb and they were
very pleased with it all in fact of
course stalin knew everything about the
bomb because he had spies in los alamos
he had a spy class [ __ ] who was
actually at the trinity test he was
sending back information all the time
and there was a recorded conversation
that took place between molotov foreign
minister and stalin after that event
that very night this is recorded where
stalin actually turns to molotov and
says right he says we have to get
kuchitov onto this and start getting him
moving kochitov was the soviet
oppenheimer and what they meant by that
was right we are now in the arms race
and we've got to get moving so in a way
the the cold war is born
in that conversation at that table in
potsdam
and the fighters
yeah very briefly the fighter planes
there were no flight planes
nothing happened there weren't there was
no flack i mean there's no anti-aircraft
fire it was nothing and one of the
reasons why that happened was because
the japanese
there'd been a number of practice
missions that these guys had flown
carrying sort of what they call pumpkin
bombs which are very very big bombs but
they were conventional bombs um and they
would they were deliberately flying
these missions with one or two or three
airplanes quite unlike the classic big
bomber raid missions that the [ __ ] the
americans were usually flying and they
were doing it with the express and
specific purpose of getting the japanese
used to high-flying airplanes that did
virtually no damage at all
and uh and and it worked i mean tibbetts
says this very expressly in his
autobiography it worked they flew this
mission i mean what on earth is one or
two or three planes gonna do nothing
they're not dangerous maybe a
reconnaissance mission whatever and
there's so little fuel left that they're
saving their fighter planes for the
serious stuff which are the incendiary
rates so they weren't touched they
weren't touched actually you know
something tibbetts said after the war
that the hiroshima mission was the most
boring mission he'd ever flown
which in a way is a terrifying
advertisement for my book but it's also
astonishingly revealing about how
perfect that mission was it was the
perfect mission
last one i'm sorry i'm being told it's
the last question yes well
first of all i would like to say that uh
today is the last day
uh for me to be a japanese tomorrow i'm
going to be a u.s citizen
after living here for 33 years i finally
decided to become a u.s citizen i'm
going to swear into my life
i thought i have known about hiroshima a
lot naturally as a japanese but i am
really looking forward to read your book
to get more detailed information two
very very basic questions uh number one
is that when this manhattan project has
been conceived
has this been specifically designed to
bomb japan have has american ever
thought of dropping this bomb to germany
to end the war
uh that's number one number two question
is that uh you say uh somebody liked
kyoto so much and he wanted to preserve
kyoto but why hiroshima why not tokyo
why not hokkaido or why not any other
place okay
um to take each question and term
briefly
let me tell you a briefly a little story
the scientist um
leo zillard who's an hungarian scientist
a hungarian jewish scientist uh fled um
actually very presently fled
berlin in 1933
uh he was working at the kaiser wilhelm
institute which is a major physics
department he was a nuclear physicist
and and this is before anyone thought
about atom bombs um he came to london
and he was standing on a street corner
in
bloomsbury um in the part of london
and
he was staring at the traffic light
and in the moment that the traffic light
changed this is his words not mine from
red to green
he suddenly saw how an atom bomb would
work
he actually saw what we now call the
chain reaction he saw how it could work
in that instant
and an abyss opened up in front of him
he'd come from nazi germany and he
suddenly thought my god if i've thought
this there might be some german
scientist on a street corner in berlin
who has exactly the same inspiration on
some other you know traffic light
junction
and
it so terrified him that he then
campaigned to get the atomic bomb built
by the americans or the british to stop
or to get ahead of the germans doing
exactly the same thing and he finally
managed to enlist the help of his
teacher einstein and together they
drafted a letter to the president
roosevelt at the time in which they
urged the president to construct atomic
bombs to get a program going and
roosevelt famously uh told his um his
aide a man called general parr watson he
opened a bottle of napoleon brandy and
he said par he said this requires action
and thus began what we call the
manhattan project its fundamental
purpose
was to
make sure
that the americans had an answer to a
german atomic bomb not to a japanese
atomic bomb
and when it was quite clear by late 1944
early 1945 the germans did not have an
atomic bomb and were actually way behind
the americans they were they got
somewhere but it was still way behind
partly because hitler loathed what he
called jewish physics associated
einstein with it
um
the next obvious target was japan the
japanese had a very fledgling atomic
program but it hardly got anywhere at
all and people like leo zillard
turned against the very program that he
had been so hard campaigning for because
he couldn't see the point of it any
longer he said what on earth are we
developing this weapon for which will be
such a terror for future generations
when actually the japanese are not an
atomic threat he even petitioned the
president at one point to stop this
thing from being developed just before
it was dropped in hiroshima and his
petition which was signed by 69
scientists at the university of chicago
actually went via general groves god
help us and as a result of that general
grove stuck the petition in his draw
and it never got to president roosevelt
never saw and president truman forgive
me he never saw it
so you're absolutely right it wasn't
japan and very briefly uh on the issue
of of hiroshima
as the chosen target and why it was
number two
hiroshima
satisfied a number of criteria which are
expressly and explicitly described in
the minutes of the target selection
committee which took place both in los
alamos and also here the pentagon just
around the corner
he
the the target was a perfect target
it was untouched by bombs virtually
um all these other cities are saying
lauren have been pulverized
it could show the effects of an atomic
bomb very clearly it also had one very
very major advantage it was surrounded
in three sides by mountains
and very expressly a number of the
people involved in that target selection
committee describe how the mountains
would create a focusing effect which
would increase the blast from the bomb
so it was untouched its geography was
bomb perfect you know
the weather patterns looked good there
they checked the weather for the last
150 years
150 years in order to see where the best
bombing days would be and it came down
to somewhere in early august
and they picked out two or three
possible days the weather was good there
and it
was in some sense also a japanese
military installation there were 43 000
japanese troops in the city but there
were also 300 000 inhabitants as well
that were not actually in the army at
all and interestingly enough when the
president made his statement that i
mentioned before broadcast his statement
to the world that he dropped this bomb
i've seen various different drafts of
that statement in an earlier drafts that
statement
it just says 16 hours ago a bomb was
dropped on blank
city name to be provided
when the name hiroshima was put in there
was a series of debates and discussions
that took place with the secretary of
war in long island and it was decided to
add the phrase an important japanese
army base that was actually added at the
very last moment added any hours before
the president actually broadcast that
statement to the world that was not in
earlier drafts of the statement so it
was important to provide worldwide
justification for the use of that bomb
even then
i'll answer your question
[Applause]
stephen walker is director of a bbc
documentary on the bombing of hiroshima
shockwave countdown to hiroshima is
published by harpercollins for more
information visit harpercollins.com
[Music]